[Music]
coming up on world stories avian flu in
South Africa
peace and quiet in Hong Kong but we
begin in Germany where a series of
attacks has been taking place in Berlin
cars have been set on fire individuals
threaten what those targeted have in
common is their stance against racism so
far the police have yet to make any
arrests
Noah Cohn is a berlin boro that's become
a magnet for hipsters it has some of the
coolest cafes in the capital and
pleasant old apartment buildings the
neighborhood is multicultural and lively
but there's another side to no cone
there have been 50 incidents there
involving right-wing extremists over the
past two years heinz Osterman runs a
bookshop in my cone he's been one of the
targets he came under attack when he
spoke out against racism and right-wing
populism in water I know it's in
determines if my shop window was smashed
in December 2016 the following month and
my car was torched right in front of my
home for my house and now this February
the same thing happens with my new car
that's Fox work he says it's quite clear
that the perpetrators are far-right
extremists and want to intimidate him
the single faces changed my life I've
become more cautious here in the
bookshop I've tried to identify any
security weak spots when I Drive home
always think about the best place to
park then when I walk from my car to my
house if there are somebody behind me I
might cross the road oh you never know
what they might be up to the police
suspect the culprits are local residents
and may have links to the far right NPD
party it's been campaigning against
immigrants and the political left for
years
MPD members are known to have committed
a significant number of acts of violence
in Nikon and elsewhere
Sebastian Schmidt Kerr is an NPD
activist I asked him what he thinks of
the allegations that the culprits may be
affiliated with his party a NPD does not
support violence against people with
different political views foreigners or
anyone else as a political tool what we
say is if we want to change things than
only by parliamentary or political means
Schmitt himself has been charged with
violent crimes though acquitted each
time he has however been found guilty of
incitement he's also known to have
associated with violent neo-nazis the
police are investigating the far-right
seen over the incidents in my cone
the recent outbreak of violence on the
border between Israel and the Gaza Strip
has left many dead and badly injured DWS
Tania claimer
traveled to bite lahia in the north of
Gaza to meet a family whose son was one
of those shot dead by the Israeli
military Mohammed's life has been turned
upside down his youngest brother bada
was killed last week in the protests a
reminder of a life lost here in the
north of Gaza a family is in mourning if
the March gives us our rights
everyone should participate but if there
is no result and if our young people
just die then we only have God to calm
their souls Mohamed says that bada was
standing next to him when he was shot in
the head there were just a few hundred
meters from the border fence
despite his brother's death Mohamed says
he will keep on protesting for young
people like him there's not much hope
left in Gaza I took part in the protests
all of us should participate because
there's no work there's no life and
nobody cares about us human rights
organizations have sharply criticized
the use of excessive force [ __ ] Suhani a
human rights lawyer from Gaza was at the
border
we thought that demonstrators I mean
lying and falling like flies I mean
snipers were shooting at the forefront
of the head or in the back head or at
the berries of the people men women
young began to fall and tens of them
were around of us it can be anybody it's
your lottery number snipers picking any
target and they are shooting at but
people of all ages have continued to
gather in the border area like here in
eastern Gaza City Hamas and other
factions set up a tent city as a
reminder of Palestinian refugees
people are now gathering old tires and
taking them to the border they plan to
set them on fire to shield protesters
from Israeli sniper fire
South Africa was badly affected by bird
flu in 2017 its poultry industry called
millions of birds in an effort to lessen
the epidemic now the disease has spread
to the countries penguins and other
seabirds
at boulders beach south of Cape Town
this penguin appears to be in good shape
but this is one of the sites where cases
of the highly pathogenic h5n1 detected
in seabirds including African penguins
17 birds have tested positive so far the
virus strain is not considered dangerous
to humans African penguins are an
endangered species their numbers are
estimated at 22,000 with populations
declining rapidly in recent years still
the state veterinarian of Western Cape
Province says the recent cases of h5n8
are not cause for major concern so far
they no signs that it's having a severe
effect on the population but we are
doing everything we can to make sure
that it doesn't need that this isn't a
contributor to the extinction of the
African penguin the aim is to prevent
transmission through humans we can't
vaccinate wild birds so all we can do is
make sure that humans don't pick up a
bird that is infected and then touch
another bird that's infected the
infestation is part of the bird flu
epidemic that's been spreading in South
Africa for nearly a year
the virus has mostly affected poultry in
the province of Western Cape alone
officials ordered the slaughter of
nearly three million chickens Hendrik
Lowe manages South Africa's largest bird
sanctuary he's deeply concerned about
the spread of the bird flu virus that it
used to be one of our biggest waterfall
enclosures which nowadays this is one of
the first enclosures that this deposit
of them over a hundred waterfowling and
they all have to be called no had to put
down five hundred Birds researchers
suspect that wild fowl such as geese and
ducks may have transported the virus to
Africa from Southeast Asia the refuge
called world of birds has been under
quarantine since last September visitors
are allowed but no birds can enter or
exit for now back at boulders beach
hopes are high that the African penguins
will be spared new infections too
now for a look at one of the world's
favorite cities Hong Kong finding a
quiet corner here can take some doing
but as with everything else in the
territory money will buy you anything
even a moment or two to enjoy some calm
reflection it's not a place that people
would associate with rest and relaxation
in Hong Kong the pursuit of quiet can be
challenging whether by day or by night
[Music]
while some visitors may find the crowds
and noise intriguing the locals do not
always find them enjoyable
[Music]
if you want to eat something it's better
to book ahead otherwise you might end up
waiting for an hour so for a table it's
so crowded on the weekends that you
can't even walk properly shopping areas
like this are very full but you can find
some quieter places further out there
are plenty of undisturbed places in Hong
Kong but there are often remote some
Hong Kong s don't mind traveling a long
way to put the chaos of the city behind
them but even the countryside is getting
more and more crowded say hikers like
Ming Qing Wang that often happens
because of the media readers may be
astonished to hear these beautiful
places in Hong Kong but they're not big
enough to support a lot of visitors so
once a place gets famous it'll almost
certainly get overrun by people and
perhaps another reason why people turn
to the countryside green urban areas are
also jam-packed is there an undisturbed
and accessible place for Hong Kong's
busy citizens to chill out here's an
attempt right in one of the city's
busiest districts
[Music]
silence is for sale in this cafe called
still house coffee tea or sometimes a
piece of cake these are the only items
that customers can order in exchange for
a moment of peace and quiet
Muchin own still house the artist hopes
to space can give people's minds a break
yeah let me show you all do you get Hong
Kong today everyone needs a moment in
space to be alone 24/7 they go home if
you interact with others 24/7 at some
point you lose sight of what you really
want from life
that one has to actually pay for silence
fair enough
say some customers for them the cafe
gives them a unique experience not even
nature can provide
but the opposite of a hectic life
doesn't necessarily have to be silence
[Music]
music also provides a good escape on
lazy afternoon
[Music]
you